the scale of child sexual abuse in
rotherham is devastating almost one and
a half thousand children many groomed by
gangs of mostly asian men and now a
report by the police watchdog has called
out the failings of the force that
should have protected them
they were treated like criminals and in
some cases some of those
poor young girls now have
criminal records
you know so in essence they were not
believed and told they were responsible
for their own behaviour when really they
were victims of really serious crime
the independent office for police
conduct looked at how south yorkshire's
force investigated child sex abuse
between 1997 and 2013.
they found there was a culture where
vulnerable individuals in the town were
seen as problems with police ignoring
glaring warning signs like finding
children in cars or even a bedroom with
older men
the iopc investigated 47 police officers
eight were found to have a case to
answer for misconduct six for gross
misconduct the most severe sanction was
a final written warning but no one was
sacked and in many cases officers had
retired and couldn't face disciplinary
proceedings
south yorkshire police have apologized
and say attitudes and procedures today
are very different from what they were
back then the challenge was that they
didn't recognize the vulnerability that
the these children were displaying and
didn't treat them
didn't treat them as children and didn't
treat them as victims why would they not
treat children as children
well i think that the main problem was
that people just didn't recognize the
vulnerability that was being displayed
but sammy woodhouse a survivor of
grooming is infuriated by this response
no one has been fired people have
retired they've got their pensions so it
kind of just feels to me that you know
they've been rewarded
um
and you know we're left picking all the
pieces up we've had our lives ruined
we're talking about children as young as
you know 10 11 13 14 years old and what
their excuses are well we didn't see
them as children how can you not see
those children
the report says policing has changed
considerably but in south yorkshire it's
also about building trust and making
sure those who are abused feel they'll
finally be listened to becky kotchel sky
news rotherham